yeah so we're going to be talk about elf
functions I want to give give you an
example first of all of one elf function
that I think II probably would recognize
and this is the Riemann zeta function
which depends on a complex number s is X
plus iy I here is the square root of -1
and you can define it either by a sum
over the integers all the integers or
the positive ones or and this is a great
discovery of Euler you can write it as a
product over the prime numbers and so
the zeta function encodes information
about the primes it contains all the
primes and if you can unravel how the
information in the zeta function is
encoded you can determine properties of
the Prime's that's one of the L
functions now let me tell you a little
bit more about the Riemann zeta function
because that's going to be part of the
story so the Riemann zeta function is
defined as a sum over the integers or a
product over the primes and there's this
formula work if X is greater than 1 but
it turns out you can find formulae that
match these when X is greater than 1 but
when X is less than 1 work as well and
here's what the Riemann zeta function
looks like
so these formally work to the right of
the line x equals 1 so they work out
here and they tell you the value of the
Z function anywhere in this in this
region now it turns out the zeta
function has this amazing symmetry which
was discovered by Riemann which says
that the line that I've drawn in blue
there that passes through the point 1/2
that's a symmetry line of the Riemann
zeta function so if I know the value of
the Z function at some point here I
reflect that point through the blue line
to get a point here and know its value
here so I can determine that very easily
so Riemann's reflection formula the
symmetry formula tells us that because I
know the zeta function in this range I
also know it in this range that's the
reflection so that just leaves this
strip which we don't understand and this
strip is where the Z function is really
mysterious we know that in this strip
there are infinitely many points where
the zeta function takes the value 0 the
belief is and this is called the Riemann
hypothesis that these points where the
zeta function takes the value 0
all lie exactly on the symmetry line and
this is called the Riemann hypothesis
and this is one of the great mysteries
of mathematics Riemann hypothesis in
1859 and it's been tested hugely since
professor it's it's well known in
mathematics that if any mathematician
can prove the Riemann hypothesis he or
she is destined for greatness yeah why
well because the the Riemann
zeta-function encodes information about
the prime so if we know the positions of
the zeroes that tells us really
important information about the prime
numbers what information what does it
tell you that you don't already know it
tells us things we already suspect
because we sort of believe the Riemann
hypothesis is true but the things we
can't prove so for example how many
Prime's are there up to a trillion we
have a formula for that that we believe
is true but we can only prove that
formula if we know the Riemann
hypothesis is true so it's like a whole
bunch of houses would suddenly have a
foundation absolutely and there are
whole books written assuming the truth
of the Riemann hypothesis so the
foundations of our understanding of the
primes would disappear if the Riemann
hypothesis turned out to be false it's
known there are infinitely many zeroes
of the riemann zeta function inside the
critical strip and it's known that at
least 40% of those do lie on the
symmetry line it's known and this is a
result of hugely extensive computations
that the first ten trillion zeros lie
exactly on the symmetry line that's the
first 10,000 billion it's known that
batches of zeros much higher up beyond
the 10 trillion lie on the line so that
I think the world record at the moment
is there's a batch of zeros up beyond
the 10 to the 36th 0 that is the billion
billion billion billion zero somewhere
up there there's a whole batch term
which we know lie exactly on the line so
people have put a huge effort into this
and there's a long history of this that
Alan Turing was when he built the first
electronic computer one of the first
things he did was compute the zeros of
the CT function and he found about the
first thousand Bly on the line professor
if a mathematician one day finds a zero
in the strip but not on the line is that
mathematician going to be a hero or a
pariah
well they would certainly be very famous
and I think people do mathematicians are
very sanguine about this they'll just
accept the truth they want to know the
truth that puts that person would be
famous but I think it would be a kind of
ugly kind of Fame not a beautiful kind
of Fame so we've got these properties
and this is what I want to emphasize we
can write the zeta function as a sum
over the integers or as a product over
the primes and the zeta function has a
symmetry line a reflection symmetry line
and we believe that all the zeros of the
zeta function around that line light
exactly on it this is what this is one
of the great mysteries in mathematics
and people have spent 150 odd years
thinking about this and one natural way
if you've given a mystery is to try to
understand well they is this a more
general property so other other
functions which look like the Riemann
zeta-function
and maybe by finding lots of those
functions and comparing them that tells
you the essential properties that make
the Riemann hypothesis true maybe allow
us to prove it so an example would be
you know if you think about evolution
doll we wanted to sort of establish
evidence for evolution so he goes to the
Galapagos Islands and he has to find
lots of finches that are all very
similar but not identical and by making
comparisons of the similarities and the
differences you then understand the
essential properties that led them to
sort of evolve as they did so we want to
find the cousins of the Riemann
zeta-function
to see whether there are any what might
you do well you might look at this some
of the integers and you might change
some of these plus signs into minus
signs and see well can you change have
any combination of pluses and minuses
here and it turns out it's very rare
that by changing some of these pluses
into minuses you can write this sum the
resulting sum as a product over primes
that will be slightly different to this
product but would resemble it and that
you'd have something that had a symmetry
line so it's very very rare that that
happens so what is one example of one
let me go back to the Riemann
zeta-function
we're going to split the primes up into
two classes two will always be special
we'll leave that as it is but the odd
Prime's will either be if you divide
them by four they'll have either a
remainder of one or three so you divide
three by four all the ranges through
divide 5 by 4 the remainders 1 because 5
is 4 plus 1 7 divide that by 4 the
remainder is 3 11 is 3 and 13 is 1 so
the ones the div is that are divisible
where the remainder is 3 will flip their
side so we put that a 1 there we will
put a 1 there a 1 there and we'll do the
other two then that gives you an L
function which has a symmetry property
if you expand these products out you go
to sum over the integers exactly at the
room Z function so this is an example of
a function which is an L function a lot
of these were discovered in the 19th
century there are infinitely many of
them you think they were rare yeah but
but despite the fact they're infinitely
many they're extremely rare amongst all
possible combinations of pluses and
minuses that you can have there so we
know they're infinitely many other
functions that look like the Riemann
zeta function you can write them as a
sum of the integers you can write them
as a product over the primes they have a
symmetry line and we believe they all
have a Riemann hypothesis so that was
the 19th century then in the 20th
century people found other examples of
functions that have those properties you
can write them as sums over the integers
or products over the primes they have a
symmetry line and we believe they have a
Riemann hypothesis and one of the heroes
in this story is Ramanujam so Ramanujam
was studying the following function x
times 1 minus x to the power 24 1 minus
x squared to the power of 24 times 1
minus x cubed to the power of 24 times 1
minus x to the 4 to the power of 24
etcetera you get the point and what he
discovered was that he could write this
as a sum of powers of X as 1 times X
minus 24 times x squared this is
something you can do at home use
multiply this thing out minus 24 times x
squared plus 2 5 2 times X cubed minus 1
4 7 2 times X to the power 4 etc this
just goes on and you get these beautiful
whole numbers coming out now here's the
miracle 2 times 3 is 6 minus 24 times
252 is - 6040 8 so these numbers have
the property that for example 3 times 5
is 15 and if I go out to the 15th number
in this series the the coefficient there
the integer that appears is 252 times
4830 this meant you could associate an L
function with these things so here's
what you do you write 1 minus 24 over 2
to the s plus 2 5 2 over 3 to the S
minus 1 4 7 2 over 4 to the S Plus 4 8 3
0 over 5 to the S etc and this series
follows from Ramanujan's observation and
a couple more observations that I won't
sort of explain in any more detail it
follows that you can write this series
as a product of primes
just as we did for the Riemann
zeta-function you can plot that in the
complex plane and it has a symmetry line
exactly like the Riemann zeta-function
dares and the zeros of this function are
believed to satisfy Riemann hypothesis
now these functions are a class of
functions called modular forms they have
certain symmetry properties which we
believe give rise to the kind of general
patterns that you see in the Riemann
zeta function that is a symmetry line
and zeros on that line a Riemann
hypothesis and these were studied
throughout the 20th century and Andrew
Wiles in his great work on Fermat's Last
Theorem use this connection between
modular forms that is functions like
this and L functions that is functions
like this to prove Fermat's Last Theorem
for all these old functions we believe
there's a Riemann hypothesis so the big
goal is to say well can we find the
patterns can we see any similarities
that would give us a clue as to why the
Riemann hypothesis is true for any of
them and
one of the things that's been done
recently is to produce a huge database
of millions of these l functions with
all their properties tabulated in a very
clear and simple way and basically the
idea is to throw this out to the world
and say can you help us find the pattern
and what you'll find there is the
Riemann zeta-function
you'll find Ramanujan's l function
you'll find the l functions that Andrew
Weil studied you'll find even more
exotic and weird l functions that we
believe all have a Riemann hypothesis
and if you go to this website you'll
find their zeroes you'll find plots
these L functions what's the pattern if
I go to this database though I'm not
going to make a breakthrough am I surely
there's only a resource for
mathematicians well it's a resource for
mathematicians but but I think these
properties are accessible to a wide
range of people this database is set up
so if you click on any technical word up
comes an explanation of that word now
you probably need to know some
mathematics to understand that but
looking at the pictures as something
that anyone can do and somewhere in
there there is a pattern that
mathematicians haven't spotted so it may
well be that somebody else spots it it's
not likely but it is possible too big
there's a little rhyme for this a rhyme
is a Chevy step said it and I'll say it
again there's always a prime between N
and 2n riemann did precisely that he
explained how to extend the this
function to all possible values except
for one so there's only one value where
there is nothing you can do